obviously this musk is number one but in
the media space
the game changed yesterday 700 000
people are watching this thing and it
crashes but you kiss 700 000 people live
in a room are waiting for this and they
have to go on Sax's account because
musk's 130 million messed up the
algorithm so they went on sax got 650
and it was fine everybody could listen
to everything that was being said and
this the centers made this announcement
yeah I think I think uh Twitter is going
to be I've said this the day uh musk
bought Twitter I did a video and I said
Twitter's going to be a trillion Auto
Company okay what they're about to do
with Twitter it's scary what are they
about yeah oh my God what a great setup
this is why you need to be president
what we're about to do to China we'll be
back after the break
but we need to do it together if that's
going to be the case
but uh but you know what the whole
Twitter thing okay so YouTube right now
there's an audience that's worried about
what's gonna happen with YouTube okay
um but Rumble is winning because of what
YouTube is doing it's a badge of honor
right now for some people to say I got
kicked out of YouTube I don't think
that's a strategy but I don't think
that's a good strategy I don't know why
people are doing it YouTube give me six
tracks screw these guys I will never use
YouTube again brother go look at history
13 years ago or 12 years ago competitor
came to YouTube one of the guys in the
marketplace took a bunch of YouTubers
off they went all to the other platform
it lasted for a few years and then it
flapped and everybody came begging back
at YouTube so you got to be pumping your
brakes a little bit now having said that
I think I hope Rumble makes it and I
hope they kill it because they're very
necessary to keep YouTube worst Yeah the
more Rumble gets bigger the better it is
for YouTube creators My Hope Is Rumble
becomes a 20 40 100 billion Auto Company
go light it up but what I think would
happen before they become 100 billion
dollar company must go by Rumble uh uh
either either he will buy Rumble
um I think sax sits on the board of
Rumble now or something like that an
announcement was made this week so it's
a very interesting sexism was trusted
guy to Musk feel is also involved with
Rumble feel sax musk all go back to the
PayPal mafia they could come up and
scoop up Rumble and say hey can you fix
all these things sacks before we buy it
yeah okay here's 5 billion come to us
we're going to put it under uh Twitter
and we're gonna use the technology the
way we want to because now sax is in
there to give us ideas then they're
going to control communication uh WeChat
model that's in Asia then they're going
to pay Talent more than anybody else is
paying them with the subscription model
uh pay you know pay my they're going to
do so many different things who is the
number one customer service
representative in America today it's
worth 200 billion dollars he reads what
people say
you can't get any Fortune 500 Co to come
out there and talk to its customers
they're locked up in the 80th floor all
the way to the top and they don't go
around talking to people this guy's like
okay let us look good point we'll work
on that it's not a bad idea let us look
into it so what do you mean by this this
is a very this is a revolutionary type
of guy muscus he'll be the first
trillionaire in America I think it's
going to take three to seven years
closer to seven but depending on what
happens to the economy Could Happen
three years I think in seven years ago
as a first trillionaire do you think
it's a bad use of his time to be
responding to people in that way no not
too how long should he do it for
you you have to know if you're as
curious as he is you know people who are
using your product know more about the
product than you do you only have one
lens okay you have to get all the lenses
that you show your blind spots like even
right here right okay you know he's
doing what he's doing but that guy's
gonna say look at the camera this way
move that can you see that the logos
that we're not getting sponsored how
about this musk has that do you know
what it is it's it's very very unique
it's like Conor McGregor saying that
he's gonna fight again who knows if he's
gonna fight again but the fact that his
name is in the conversation is good for
the alcohol brand he has it's good for
the entertainment brand he has good for
the management company because his brand
is wrapped around him as a fighter not
him as a retired fighter Elon answering
five tweets a day is just a reminder you
know I'm listening I'm here and this is
my company an attention Lottery that's
it that's it so not only tweet at me but
know when you're tweeting you're
tweeting on elon's platform you're
driving a Tesla that's elon's car and
all of us are literally invested in Elon
if some random person bought Tesla I'd
probably take my money out of Tesla
I I'm invested in Elon and Tesla is my
ability to invest in Elon the man if
there was a stock that was just Elon
stock
and it kind of wrapped up all his
different Ventures we would invest in
that I think that's pretty fast but I
don't think you're buying Facebook stock
you're buying Zuckerberg stock
whatever it ipo'd in 20 whatever that
was the line of thing that I was told by
my uncle he bought it and I was like I'm
hearing not good things he's like I
don't care I trust this this kid knows
what's going on now he might be out of
his depth whatever but that was
initially the comparison I was making